now at least 41 people have been killed
in a fire at a prison in indonesia the
blaze at the tangarang jail near the
capital jakarta has now been put out
more than 78 people were injured well
jessica washington is at the scene in
tengarang and joins us live jessica so
just talk us through what more details
are now emerging about the fire
darn we're just outside the prison at
the main gate and we are still waiting
uh for information to come forward this
is still a developing situation as you
mentioned more than 70 people injured
among them we know that eight people
were critically injured and some of them
have burns to more than 98
of their body now so far the cause of
the fire is still being investigated
authorities say that potentially the
cause of the fire may have been an
electrical short circuit and that there
may have been a shortage of fire
extinguishers on the scene now local
authorities from the tangarang fire
department were able to extinguish the
blaze within about an hour but in that
time as you mentioned at least 41 people
lost their lives now it is important to
look at this safety incident in the
broader context we have known for many
years now that overcrowding has been a
problem in indonesian prisons and human
rights activists have long called to
rectify that issue and they've long
called for criminal justice reform uh in
particular to seek alternatives rather
than detention for those guilty of minor
offenses but despite those calls for
years
that has not yet happened and this
prison as we understand like many across
indonesia also faced overcrowding it had
capacity for around 600 prisoners but
there were more than 2 000 inmates at
the time of this fire now some prisons
in indonesia are at 300 to even 400
capacity and human rights activists say
that incidents such as what we have what
happened today simply should not happen
jessica thank you